et time a vu sa peine le raid s'est
jamais moment ils m'appellent maman
oh là là ça va ça est parti les souris
pas comme un soufflet catalan ou face à
des messins la coupe et ciani n'ont pas
tous quasiment rien du tout est ce que
j'ai trouvé dans son sac induits sur
cette photo aucune idée oh pas photo et
pourquoi tu dois filer la bagnole quand
tu vois bien qu'ils inoffensif on dirait
un chat perdu mais le chien perdu on lui
donne aux palourdes yayi c'est votre
femme qui lui a prêté deux véhicules n'y
a pas eu vol qui est prêt bon alors je
pourrai voilà je porte plainte pour près
c'est sûrement un enfant abandonné ou
alors c'est peut-être ton fils tu m'as
déjà trompée elle s'appelle commandes
s'étaient pas le bon endroit
on va aller la voir la confiance dont je
t'en prie aux mondiaux mais comment tu
as pu bernos a fait les 42 - ou en fait
imaginer en train de glace venu
présenter sa femme pieds de vos pairs au
son de ma voix peut-être un c'est tout
droit pas ici oui mon dieu tu vas voir
un petit fils entré par sapiens les
foules
comment vous vous êtes rencontrés car un
site de rencontre le résident de
rencontres aux handicapés annonce-t-il
de kull ceux qui pètent un discours
aussi introduit chez les gens pour les
dépouiller et voilà c'est un beau cadeau
pour ton mariage ça t'intéresse pas de
comprendre qu'ils gamin veux pas essayer
de me faire confiance pour une fois toi
tu peux toujours avoir des enfants mais
elle et vit ça comme un deuil
supporter de rien connard connaît un nom
un canard donc j'ai dit à canal